some people argue that individuals in
the United States making 250,000 dollars
a year
belong to the middle class others
disagree but the term middle class is
ambiguous what it means depends on who
you ask so let's ask what are some ways
to define the middle class a 2010
international study defined the global
middle class as households that spend
between 10 and $100 per person per day
but this definition becomes skewed in
more wealthier poor nations India for
instance considers their middle class to
be households that spend at least four
dollars a day here in the US an average
American spends closer to 95 dollars a
day companies often define the middle
class by looking at purchasing power in
developing countries like India or China
the middle class often refers to people
who can afford appliances in wealthy
countries the middle class can afford
larger purchases like cars since the
1960s the United Kingdom has measured a
social grade not by income but by
occupation a skilled manual worker is
still seen as working class while a
clerk is middle class even though the
manual worker may be making several
times with the clerk takes home in the
United States where class is usually
defined by money the median income is
about 52 thousand dollars a year
definitions like these don't indicate
that a two hundred and fifty thousand
dollar a year earner would qualify as
middle-class but according to a 2010 BDO
study between mortgages taxes and child
care an average family of four in
Huntington New York would actually incur
two hundred and seventy seven thousand
dollars worth of expenses effectively
going into the red on only two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year the
middle class is an effective talking
point for politicians and economists
because it's so malleable but for
settling debates about specific numbers
this ambiguous phrase leaves something
to be desired
fired